una reapertura lenta y progresiva a
partir de ahora y hasta el 20 de enero
francia empezará a retomar varias
actividades con el fin de concluir el
segundo confinamiento obligatorio en el
país a raíz del coi 19 el presidente
francés detalló su plan de reapertura
asegurando que lo peor de la segunda ola
de la pandemia había terminado
doble de plasma en primer lugar se
permitirá salir de la casa para pasear y
hacer ejercicio al aire libre en un
radio de 20 kilómetros y durante tres
horas se permitirá nuevamente las
actividades escolares extracurriculares
al aire libre se permitirá la
reanudación de los servicios religiosos
con un límite estricto de 30 personas
límites de counters macrón dijo además
que las vacunaciones contra el virus
empezarán a principios de 2021 con
prioridad a los más frágiles en cuanto a
italia el país registró este martes 800
53 muertes porque hoy 19 lo que
representa la cifra más alta desde
finales de marzo el gobierno aún decide
qué medidas adoptar para el periodo
navideño aunque los expertos aseguran
que no hay que bajar la guardia el plan
de españa para navidad se centra en las
noches del 24 y 31 de diciembre cuando
solo se podrán reunir un máximo de seis
personas en cuanto al plan de vacunación
contra el coi 19 el ministro de salud
dijo que empezará a partir de enero les
anunció que los residentes y el personal
sanitario y sociosanitario en
residencias de personas mayor de
personas mayores y con discapacidad
serán los primeros grupos que se
vacunarán francas
frente al kobryn 19 les seguirá el resto
del personal sanitario y grandes
dependientes no institucionalizados
aunque las hospitalizaciones se han
reducido la situación continúa
agravándose en países como rusia austria
y bulgaria que registraron en la última
jornada récords de muertes